faut être efficace parce qu'on est quand
même en cave il faut pas trop qu'on
traîne ici
[Musique]
ils ont un téléphone tu me le
géolocalises
nous avons
McFly et Carlito
Jennifer Bartoli et Jarry Michou et
inoxtag fabili Camara et Hakim jemili
allez c'est parti on va leur montrer ce
qu'on sait faire au boulot allez
on a un objectif c'est fuir on court
comme des malades j'ai pas besoin
une autre idée restée dans la région
c'est là où on a nos complices
mon frère elle est pas discrète la
voiture
elle fait plus de bruit que toute ta
famille
on est parti sur des déguisements un
petit peu réalistes je m'appelle Pamela
seurs ils vont devenir fou ils sont dans
laquelle ils sont trop fort les gars
c'est ça le pied de nez aux enquêteurs
[Musique]